Bonsai 27B needs 54 GB of memory to run
at full precision. [music] This week,
the absolute mad lads made it run on an
iPhone. 27 billion parameters [music] in
under 4 GB at 11 tokens a second, all
without touching the internet. [music]
It fits because Prism ML threw away 15
of the 16 bits in every single weight.
What's left of each number is a plus or
a minus sign,
>> [music]
>> and they claim it still keeps 90% of its
benchmark scores. Is that a legit
breakthrough or a flat-out lie? First,
why 54 [music]
GB? A model's knowledge lives in its
weights, 27 billion numbers, and by
default, each one is stored as a 16-bit
float.
2 bytes, 27 billion times over. Got it?
Bonsai's base model is dense, meaning
every single one of those weights works
on every token it generates without
shortcuts. [music]
Phone is a harsher target than the spec
sheet suggests. The iPhone it ran on has
12 GB of RAM, but iOS lets a single app
claim only about six before the system
kills it. 6 GB for everything, the
weights, the conversation history, and
the runtime. Usual fix is quantization,
storing each weight with fewer bits. A
standard 4-bit build of this exact model
still weighs 17.6 GB, closer, but still
three times over the ceiling. Getting a
dense model this size through a 6 GB
gate needed something far past the usual
trim.
What does one bit per weight even mean?
The most upvoted confusion when this
launched [music] was some version of a
bit is a zero or a one. So, how is it
holding a minus one?
>> [music]
>> Every weight in the original model is a
precise number, something like [music]
0.0173.
Bonsai one thing about it, the sign.
Positive becomes +1, negative becomes
-1, and the magnitude is gone. [music]
To stop the math from turning to mush,
the model stores one full precision
scale for every group of 128 weights, a
shared volume knob that says how loud
this whole block of signs plays. [music]
1-bit signs plus 16-bit knob [music]
works out to 1.125
bits per weight. That's the true number,
and it matches the label, which is rarer
than you'd think, [music] because quant
labels lie. The community's favorite
4-bit build of this model is really 5.2
bits [music] per weight once you count
the scales and the escape hatches. The
popular 2-bit one is 2.8. Bonsai also
ships a turnery sibling, -1, [music]
0, +1, at 1.71 bits. But the binary
build is the headline act and the one
that fits the phone. Round a finished
model's weight down to bare signs, and
it dies on the spot. Below three bits,
conventional quantization stops
degrading gracefully and collapses. Half
the Hacker News thread assumed Prism ML
dodged this by training a 1-bit model
from scratch, the way Microsoft's BitNet
does. They didn't. They took [music]
Qwen 3.6 27B, an existing dense model
from Alibaba, and retrained [music]
it with the 1-bit constraint switched on
inside the training loop, so the
optimizer learns to route around the
missing precision while it can still
adjust everything else.
Quantization-aware training, the model
heals around its own wounds. Two more
tricks on top of that. Long
conversations normally [music] blow the
memory budget a second time through the
KV cache, the model's running memory of
the context. [music]
So, Bonsai compresses that to four bits
as well. The full 262,000
token window fits in about 9 and 1/2 GB,
and the runtime never unpacks the
weights back to full precision. Custom
kernels run the matrix math directly on
the packed bits,
>> [music]
>> signs, volume knobs, and all. This last
bit is important to understand for the
love and hate of this model. Because the
reviews are unhinged. One developer on
Reddit said the one-bit [music] build
passed his personal edge case tests and
felt as good as the full model. Another
said it couldn't write CSS without
looping. A third asked it what Signals
is and got a confident wrong answer.
[music] And someone on Android received
50 exclamation marks and nothing else.
All of them were describing the real
model. Three things decide which one you
get. First, [music] the task. The damage
from the missing bits is targeted. Math
barely notices. 92 versus 95 for the
original. Coding gives up seven points,
>> [music]
>> but agentic tool calling craters from 80
to 66, and instruction following falls
13 points.
>> [music]
>> Ask it to reason and it holds. Ask it to
run a multi-step workflow and it walks
into a doom loop, failing the same step
the same way forever.
>> [music]
>> Second, language. English survives the
compression best. Push it in German or
Italian and the grammar starts
crumbling, sometimes [music] mid-word.
Third, the kernel trap. If your runtime
lacks the packed [music] one-bit math
path for your hardware, it unpacks every
weight back to eight [music] bits before
multiplying. You pay the full unpack
cost and receive none of the speed.
That's how people measured a one-bit
model running slower than a four-bit
one, and it's why a chunk of the day one
its broken posts were really, my back
end isn't supported [music] yet posts.
About that 11 tokens a second, it's real
and it's below the 15 to 20 that feels
conversational. You sent this model off
with a job and check back the way you'd
treat a slow but capable intern. The
battery number impressed me more than
the speed.
>> [music]
>> 672
tokens per 1% of battery. Roughly 67,000
tokens on a full charge. If you manage
your expectations, the use cases are
clear. One commenter stood in a grocery
store in the Alps, no signal, and had
the model on his phone plan dinner and
the shopping list. Offline, private,
[music] running on hardware you already
own. Add document analysis or
translation on a plane and you have the
honest pitch.
>> [music]
>> If you want this to be your next live
coding assistant, be prepared to cry.
The whole field slid down the precision
axis [music] in the same week. On Sloth
shipped NVFP4 quants of the very same
quant model. Four bits, [music] two and
a half times faster, aimed at big
Blackwell GPUs with memory to spare. On
a data center GPU, quantization buys you
speed. On a phone, it buys you control.
It's also a different escape hatch from
the one we covered at the start of this
week, where a giant mixture of experts
model streams its experts off an SSD.
Streaming changes where the weights
live. Quantization changes what the
weights are. Streaming [music]
wins when the model is sparse and the
disk is fast. Extreme quantization wins
when the model is dense and the memory
ceiling is a hard wall. A phone is the
hardest wall there is.
So, breakthrough or flat-out lie? The
compression is real and the phone demo
is measured on named hardware with
battery numbers attached. The 90% claim
is true as an average, and the average
height is exactly where the missing 10%
[music] lives in the gigantic workflows
developers care about most. A year ago,
one bit quants were a meme on these same
forums. Today, they run 27 billion
parameters [music] on a phone, and the
argument has moved to a harder question.
Once it fits, is it the best model you
could run in those 4 GB? Smaller model
at 4-bit sometimes wins that fight,
[music] and nobody has settled it yet.
It's clear that one bit first started as
a punchline. [music] After this week,
it's a roadmap.